ah hello this is steve kaufmann the
sixth secret of language learning
we have already had the first secret which is
to spend enough time to
be successful success to succeed to
learn a language
second thing to do pleasant things
third  thing to develop
the ability to pay attention to
notice what is happening on the
moor
fourth that vocabulary is
more important than grammar
fifth to be patient and
patient and now sixth the
sixth secret try to get all
the tools  all the instruments that
will ensure your success, for example
of course the mp3 player whatever
the brand it is not important
a contribution from ipad others when I
started my Chinese studies 50
years ago almost low there  didn't have this
kind of instrument of tools today
I fight I walk around I always say
I take my mp3 player with me and
I have a whole library of Audi  o
book in five six exercise languages
ng I can always study so th
t's very very important the i
ternet you have to you have to study
and research all the possi
ilities that exist on the internet all t
e sites with  grammar explanations
or examples where ddd
text and podcasts anything that
's very important
I love audio books
audio books italy sound books made by
professionals
cc it's fantastic I can keep it
I can  moreover put it on my
mp3 player I listen to them and this puts
going to the theater again and that's when it's
well done like that with a good
sound quality with a person who
has a beautiful voice a beautiful diction
it's  fantastic to present it
the learning of the lot the books for
example yes even if I do I work a
lot on link in my learning
of two Russians two Czechs etc but
I also buy books books there
are books of the novels that I will  is read
or even small books which
you as an introduction to the law
assimilates he believes that it is all that
it helps
depending on the person you need
different different tools but you
have to equip yourself either buy or
borrow municipal library etc
but it  it's like any job
if you have the roads the tools you
'll do your job well including a
cigarette in learning languages
ctionaries for example me on my i
od I hav
to have a lot of difficulty I hav
them  bought because the
dictionaries that I had to pay 5 or 10
dollar were much better than the
free dictionaries so clean and a
little is not much but it is
worth to be well equipped and here is the
sixth secret of the  learning the
milk thank you costs goodbye